you know being jewish is complicated
clearly
and being a famous jewish person is in
some ways a little more complicated
and um you know i
i completely and i'm i'm at peace with
that and i understand that you know
and and it's not something that i
like um i'm not surprised you know
that you know these are very sensitive
subjects and then i'm not surprised with
people
react sensitively to them there's
conflict i think every jewish person
feels i think jewish people feel a
conflict between
i mean literally there's conservative
synagogues and progressive synagogues
those were like the two synagogues my
friends
went to basically when i was a kid and
those two things are
are at odds with each other in some ways
you know um
it doesn't mean there's a lot of not a
lot of common ground amongst those
groups of people
but just taken at face value a
progressive group
and a conservative group are not going
to agree on a lot of stuff
and and i think that that conflict lies
within a lot of jewish people i know
this idea of preserving our values and
our culture and our history but also
keeping an eye towards
being as progressive and cutting edge as
possible when it comes to what is
what our progressive causes um
in general uh yeah when when progressive
and conservative or
the two things you're balancing you will
find yourself uh in conflicted positions
from time to time
[Music]
the interview was a true controversy to
me and in my opinion one of the only
true controversies i've seen happen with
like a film and a filmmaker
and having experienced that
i i have a very different barometer for
what i find to be a truly
controversial moment to my life and
career i think and
you know having almost started like an
actual you know or being at the center
of
a conversation with that people feared
might lead to
an actual war um between nuclear powers
i i think it's given me a
a different barometer for this kind of
thing in some ways